et de solidarité l'exploration au sens
large est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions à la
surface de notre planète
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous est décrypteront
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 26 octobre 2020
le président turc recep tayyip erdogan
appelle au boycott des produits français
dans la foulée de certains pays du golfe
une décision qui fait suite aux
dernières déclarations d' emmanuel
macron sur la liberté de caricaturé le
prophète mahomet la chancelière
allemande ou bien le premier ministre
italien guiseppe comptait quant à
apporter leur soutien au chef de l'état
le conseil français du culte musulman
appelle les musulmans de l'hexagone à
défendre l'intérêt de la france en
biélorussie des centaines de
travailleurs et des étudiants ont
répondu à l'appel lancé par l'opposante
vêtue la nature and of sky à a désormais
installé en lituanie le mouvement de
grève qui fait suite à un ultimatum pour
réclamer une nouvelle fois le départ du
président alexandre loukachenko à
quelques interpellations ont eu lieu
depuis le début de la journée
svetlana tirano sky a souhaité faire de
cette grève un levier de pression
économique
[Musique]
le colis qui bouscule les agendas alors
que le virgule circule de manière
extrêmement rapide sur le territoire
emmanuel macron réunira deux conseil de
défense mardi et mercredi
jean castex consultera lui les forces
politiques et les partenaires sociaux
est l'hypothèse d'un nouveau confinement
est sur la table face à une deuxième
vague brutale qui pourrait même être
plus forte que la première avertit le
professeur delfraissy président du
conseil scientifique
nous ne devons pas baisser les bras dans
la lutte contre la pandémie exhorte le
chef de l' oms
à la crise sanitaire et ses conséquences
sur l'économie du pays la question était
au centre des discussions à matignon ce
matin une conférence sociale en présence
de jean castex du ministre de l'économie
de la ministre du travail ainsi que des
représentants syndicaux et du patronat
sur la réforme de l'assurance chômage le
gouvernement n'entend pas renoncer
mais un nouveau report de trois mois de
son application a été actée
[Musique]
la tension monte d'un cran aujourd'hui
entre la france et la turquie après le
qatar le koweït et les émirats arabes
unis reach est hyper douanes appelle à
son tour à boycotter les produits
français
le président turc eux mettent en doute
les propos d' emmanuel macron sur la
laïcité et sur sa volonté de ne pas
abandonner les caricatures redshift est
hyper douanes demande a stoppé à la
campagne de haine du président français
envers les musulmans écouter une
campagne de lynchage semblable à celle
contre les juifs d'europe avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale est en train
d'être menées contre les musulmans et
plutôt emmanuel macron avait réagi aux
propos du président turc il a tenu à
rappeler que la france respectait toutes
les différences dans un esprit de paix à
écouter nous continuerons nous
respectons toutes les différences dans
un esprit de paix nous n'acceptons
jamais les discours de haine et
défendons le débat raisonnable
nous nous tiendrons toujours du côté de
la dignité humaine et des valeurs
universelles
ces appels dénaturent les positions
défendues par la france en faveur de la
liberté de conscience de la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de religion
et du refus de tout appel à la haine
en conséquence les appels au boycott
sont sans aucun objet doivent cesser
immédiatement de même que toutes les
attaques dirigées contre notre pays
instrumentalisées par une minorité
radicale les façons aux provocations du
président turc que plusieurs dirigeants
européens ont réagi notamment sur la
toile regarder les propos adressés par
le président r doan au président macron
sont inacceptables les invectives
personnelles n'est pas l'agenda positif
que l'union européenne veut poursuivre
avec la turquie mais éloigne au
contraire les solutions pleine
solidarité avec le président emmanuel
macron plutôt qu'un agenda positif la
turquie choisi les provocations les
actions unilatérales en méditerranée et
maintenant les injures c'est intolérable
respect pour l'europe et ses états
membres
je condamne les insultes du président r
doan contre le président macron
il montre à nouveau que la turquie est
toujours plus loin de l'ue eux et s'est
éloigné de nos valeurs communes soutien
total et solidarité pour la france mon
soutien total pour la france et tout le
monde libre et démocratique dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
nos efforts doivent être renforcés pour
protéger les valeurs européennes et le
renforcement de la résilience de nos
sociétés alors le disait ce sont donc
plusieurs pays musulmans qui appellent
au boycott des produits français des
pays comportant de bonnes relations avec
la france elle reste que le climat est
aujourd'hui temps du retour sur cette
polémique avec mona modèle or 22 colère
dans le monde musulman et plus
particulièrement dans les pays rigoriste
tels que l'arabie saoudite le coût est
l'iran ou encore le qatar
s'ils ont condamné l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit plusieurs états désapprouve
la position d' emmanuel macron sur la
publication des caricatures du prophète
de l'islam durant la cérémonie d'hommage
à l'enseignant samuel pâtit décapité
pour avoir montré à ses élèves des
dessins de charlie hebdo
emmanuel macron a déclaré ceci nous ne
renoncerons pas aux caricatures au
dessin même si d'autres reculs l arabie
saoudite par exemple avait exprimé sa
solidarité avec le peuple français mais
les annonces de l'elysée pour lutter
contre le séparatisme ont vite suscité
un flot de réprobation officielle comme
officieuse en jordanie pourtant allié de
la france le ministre des affaires
étrangères à ayman safadi qui n'a aucune
sympathie pour les radicaux a lui aussi
condamné la publication des caricatures
et il en est de même pour le chef de la
diplomatie marocaine depuis les appels
au boycott de produits français se
multiplient dans plusieurs pays du
moyen-orient au qatar par exemple des
chaînes de grande distribution ont ainsi
annoncé qu'elle retirait les produits
français des magasins jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
l'université du qatar a par ailleurs
décidé de reporter la semaine culturelle
française à la suite de latin délibéré à
l'islam et à ses symboles aux couettes
même son cloche les fromages français
ont été retirés des rayons de certains
magasins quelques 430 agences de voyages
chrétiennes ont suspendu les
réservations de vols
la france et certains vont même plus
loin un restaurant a par exemple poser
des photos d'emmanuel macron sur le sol
afin de permettre aux clients de
piétiner le président français et cela
peut avoir des conséquences économiques
pour la france car ces pays notamment le
qatar l'arabie saoudite et les émirats
arabes unis représentent un marché de
plus en plus important pour les
exportations de l'industrie
agroalimentaire française mais aussi
d'armement qui est source de gros
contrats entre la france et ces pays
la france a donc tout intérêt à garder
de bonnes relations mais à quel prix
si le boycott s'est vite propagé des
manifestations à gaza au maroc en
tunisie ont eu lieu avec des slogans
hostiles à l'exécutif français
toujours sur le même sujet est la
tension est montée d'un cran entre la
turquie et la france
recep tayyip erdogan qui cible le
président français depuis plusieurs
jours a également appelé au boycott de
nos produits et il est allé plus loin
une campagne de lynchage semblable à
celle contre les juifs d'europe avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale est en train
d'être menées contre les musulmans
tout comme en france certains disent
n'achetez pas les marques turc
je m'adresse ici à ma nation surtout ne
prêtait pas attention aux marques
françaises ne les achetez pas difficile
donc d'imaginer une accalmie rapide
entre les deux pays même si air doan a
condamné l'assassinât contre samuel
pâtit face à toutes ces accusations le
quai d'orsay a réagi dans un communiqué
ces appels dénaturent les positions
défendues par la france en faveur de la
liberté de conscience de la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de religion
et du refus de tout appel à la haine est
la france est donc dans une position
délicate et les enjeux sont grands
le gouvernement doit défendre corps et
âme la laïcité et lutter contre
l'intégrisme tout en maintenant des
relations commerciales importantes avec
ces pays musulmans une équation
difficile que va devoir résoudre paris
alors comment comprendre les intentions
de redjep tayyip erdogan faut-il prendre
au sérieux cette menace de boycott on en
parle tout de suite avec nos invités
c'est notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurent jacobellis porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir à vos
côtés hinan bur bus vice président de la
chambre de commerce franco turc bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france laurent jacot belli
pour commencer ses dernières
déclarations du président turc cet appel
au boycott est ce que vous le jugez
inquiétant aujourd'hui oui bien sûr il
faut le prendre au sérieux le président
turc erdogan est passé du stade des
vociférations des gesticulations à la
menace des actes avec ce bruit cote en a
vu un peu partout en syrie en libye dans
les eaux grecques qu'ils étaient prêts à
tous donc bien évidemment on peut
entendre que ce boycott il
il envisage réellement mais il faut que
le président turc que sachent que nous
ne sommes pas sans moyens de rétorsion
bien sûr nous offusquons de l'ensemble
des propos qu'il a tenus parce que nous
sommes fiers de défendre la liberté
d'expression et que pour nous ça n'a pas
de prix mais surtout il va falloir
qu'ils comprennent que la france au
travers de l'union européenne à verser
des milliards à la turquie notamment 6
milliards pour financer la politique de
migrants en turquie 9 3 milliards pour
l'adhésion à l'union européenne et bien
il faut que nous envisagions avec nos
partenaires européens de lui faire
comprendre que ces milliards
si l'allemagne les autres pays nous
suivent il faudra qu'ils les oublie donc
vous voyez nous ne sommes pas nous aussi
sans armes arms intellectuelle parce que
nous sommes fiers de nos valeurs fiers
de nos principes et arme économique
aussi in our bus avant de vous entendre
je vous propose de regarder ces chiffres
ces chiffres de la direction générale du
trésor
il concerne les principales exportations
de la france vers la turquie justement
et on voit que le secteur de
l'aéronautique représente 4 490 millions
d'euros
elle les produits sidérurgiques et 455
millions d'euros
elle les accessoires automobiles 420
millions
roh les produits pharmaceutiques 339
millions d'euros et les véhicules
automobiles 310 millions d'euros
il nomme du robuste finalement cet appel
au boycott est ce que il ne veut pas se
retourner contre la population elle même
il faut aussi remettre les choses dans
leur contexte
aujourd'hui on parle de la turquie on
parle d'un boycott mais il faut savoir
que la turquie n'est pas non plus un
petit pays que l'on peut dicter de loin
ou du moins juger parce qu'aujourd'hui
la turquie c'est 80 millions d'habitants
c'est la première puissance du
moyen-orient la septième au niveau
européenne si elle était européenne la
17e puissance mondiale
donc on a en face de nous un acteur qui
pèse qui vit son âge d'or économique
aujourd'hui vous savez il n'y a pas
beaucoup de pays dans le monde qui ont
une croissance en a les bric brésil
russie inde chine et derrière on a deux
les experts les consultants
internationaux qui placent l'indonésie
le mexique et la turquie
or en termes de croissance donc la
turquie est un acteur est un partenaire
important pour la france aujourd'hui la
turquie ça se place entre la 10e et la
15e place un haut niveau des partenaires
des échanges commerciaux c'est la 17e
puissance mondiale
donc aujourd'hui oui il faut prendre cet
appel au sérieux mais après il faut le
mesurer
je m'explique certes le président
appelle à un boycott
ça peut avoir son effet sur les produits
de grande consommation quand on
s'appelle bnp qu'on s'appelle carrefour
renault ça peut avoir un effet
effectivement mais là où c'est plus
délicat je dirais c'est plutôt au niveau
des appels d'offres publics
vous savez lorsqu'un une entreprise
française qui se positionne peut-être
pour la construction d'une centrale
nucléaire peut-être pour un barrage là
il peut avoir des effets à court terme
ou plus ou du moins une parenthèse
délicate pour les échanges entre les
entreprises françaises et turques
laurent jacobellis et ce qu'il faut
avoir en tête selon vous aujourd'hui
avec la turquie mais aussi avec tous les
autres pays du moyen-orient qui ont
appelé eux aussi à boycotter les
produits français
équation délicate finalement conservé
une économie tout de même c'est vers là
qu'il faut aller selon vous je crois
d'abord que il ne faut pas céder à la
menace vous savez si monsieur erdogan
par exemple s'en prend principalement à
la france c'est parce que ils pensent
probablement que c'est le maillon faible
de l'europe 41% des échanges commerciaux
de la turquie sont avec des pays de
l'union européenne donc monsieur regarde
non plus n'a rien à gagner à faire un
bras de force bras de fer pardon
économiques avec la france
avoir des bonnes relations commerciales
avec les pays qui aujourd'hui semble
critiquer la position de la france peut
être un objectif mais je pense qu'il va
falloir faire comprendre aussi à
monsieur erdogan qu'il faut que sa
volonté expansionniste que sa propension
à vouloir diriger l'ensemble du monde et
particulièrement l'ensemble du monde
musulman doit cesser j'aimerais quand
même vous lire la phrase du responsable
de la communication de la présidence de
la république turque qui à elle seule
mérite d'être inquiets et mérite que
nous envisagions effectivement de ne pas
nous laisser faire il dit et je le cite
aux musulmans d'europe
nous n'allons pas tendre l'autre joue
quand vous nous insulter nous allons
nous défendre et défendre les nôtres à
tout prix il vient de telles phrases de
tels propos de telles menaces ne doivent
pas simplement vous laisser regarder les
chiffres de l'économie essayer de faire
de la diplomatie câlinothérapie il faut
montrer un monsieur erdogan qu' il n'est
pas le seul à pouvoir entreprendre un
rapport de force
privilégiez bien sûr les solutions de
dialogue mais s'il veut aller plus loin
nous ne sommes pas nous le répétons sans
mesures de rétorsion possible en tout
cas j'espère que maintenant l'ensemble
des pays de l'union européenne ont
compris que la turquie dans l'union
européenne sait jamais il donne des
airbus c'est une crainte aujourd'hui de
la turquie
voire des sanctions finalement arrivé du
côté de l'union européenne
ils ont cette donne éventuel en tête ou
pas alors il faut remettre les choses
dans leur contexte encore une fois on
assiste à une propagande anti turque
décomplexé à travers toute l'europe et
ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui ni d'hier
c'est depuis 2013 que régulièrement quoi
que fasse la turquie la turquie est
toujours le mal incarné erdogan c'est le
sultan donc quoi qu'il fasse c'est
mauvais devons-nous rappeler encore une
fois mais malheureusement on le rappelle
pas en vérité dans la dans la presse
écrite française ni même dans les médias
que la turquie accueille aujourd'hui 5
millions 2,4 millions pardon de syriens
qui sont logés nourris et hébergés ils
ont la scolarité les transports gratuite
ça a un coût de plus de 40 milliards
depuis 2013
donc même là dessus là jamais on le dit
à la turquie oui là dessus vous avez été
bon oui là dessus vous vous avez
participé
on est toujours dans l'hostilité
toujours le face à face alors qu'en fait
et redonne force aussi se remettre dans
le contexte on est au moyen orient
il a un comportement orientale on est
vraiment dans l'interculturel y réagit
du tac au tac c'est à dire qu'il y ait
en mode action réaction vous allez en
orient c'est pareil donc il suffit que
ne serait ce qu'une fois la france et
une position ne serait-ce que pacifique
une position de main tendue vers la
turquie
je suis certain que here douanes qui est
un homme intelligent il n'est pas là par
hasard il a pas redresser l'économie du
pays depuis 2002 sans avoir d'inaptitude
ne serait-ce diplomatiques ou
économiques
la turquie acceptera la turquie par
exemple avec des tensions avec les états
unis avec trump puis du jour au
lendemain après des discussions après
une certaine négociations ça s'est
apaisée il ya une relation constructive
donc moi je suis candidat on est dans
une période délicate effectivement avec
cet appel au boycott mais juste certain
qu'il est possible de trouver une
discussion mais il faut que l'initiative
aussi viennent de la france parce que
les turcs sont en mode stand by on
attend on essaye on mène des actions
concrètes sur le terrain mais jamais on
est félicité laurent jacobellis
une réaction est ce que vous ne vous
venez d'entendre oui il va écouter
monsieur vous êtes au moins fidèle à
votre employeur
bravo mais ce que vous dites n'a pas de
sens
dans quelle mesure on pourrait dire
merci à la turquie qui traite le
président de la république française de
fouet en disant qu'il doit soigner sa
maladie mentale
de quel droit tu dire et on merci aux
sultans comme vous l'avait appelée de la
turquie qui menace la grèce avec ses
navires à tel point que la france est
obligée d'agir un la grèce à nos
partenaires et dale et alliés monsieur
erdogan multiplie les provocations en
fait il nous teste il veut voir jusqu'où
il peut aller
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des
migrants qui gardait sur son sol ça nous
coûte 6 milliards mais surtout ils sont
entre ses mains une monnaie des changes
puisque à chaque fois à chaque fois
pardon qu'il est mécontente
il nous menace d'ouvrir les vannes et de
déverser sur le continent européen
des milliers et des milliers de migrants
monsieur erdogan clairement un
comportement qui n'est pas un
comportement de diplomatie qui est un
comportement de rapport de force
nous le regrettons mais force est de
constater que c'est le cas c'est pas le
cas qu'en france un jésuite est la grèce
je ne pourrais parler de l'azerbaïdjan
et d'un certain nombre de fronts où la
turquie est de plus en plus offensive
donc il va falloir un moment qu'on
explique à monsieur erdogan qu'il n'est
pas seul au monde et que nous ne sommes
pas prêts à tout accepter une âme du
rebuse après les propos à leur échappe
tayyip erdogan notamment les propos qui
visaient les musulmans d'europe pour
ratchet tayyip erdogan et musulmans en
europe pour le même sort que les juifs
avant la seconde guerre mondiale
certains observateurs soulignent que de
tels propos le servent avant tout pour
rassurer ses soutiens en turquie est ce
que c'est le cas selon vous c'est une
honte du savant nantes avant de
permettre à van avant de répondre je
souhaite juste robot dont la comédie sur
les propos qui ont été tenus
je souhaite si tu es si vous le
permettez une citation de mais de là
naquit un célèbre souffler en turquie
qui disait que la vérité est un miroir
qui est tombé du ciel
chacun en détient une partie et pensent
détenir toute la vérité donc parmi les
informations que j'ai entendu bien sûr
qu'il ya une vérité mais permettez moi
aussi
d'ajouter le point de vue de la turquie
par exemple monsieur la cité 6 milliard
de dollars ou d'euros qui ont été
accordés à la turquie dans les faits il
y a à peine un tiers qui a été
réellement payé par l'union européenne
dans les faits il a fallu attendre plus
de quatre ans après 2016 pour que le
deuxième versement puisse être effectué
à ce jour on est en 2020 le paiement
n'existe pas et lorsqu'on parle de 6
milliards le coût pour la turquie c'est
6 milliards par an depuis 2000 13 faites
le calcul ça fait plus de 40 voire 50
milliards donc c'est une goutte d'eau ce
type de ce type d'arguments après on lui
dit que la turquie provoc mais elle
provoque dans quoi lorsqu'on parle des
de la grèce par exemple avec les navires
turcs y sont sur un territoire soit 10
ans grec et ben et plusieurs politiciens
turcs ont expliqué la situation ils ont
dit que c'étaient des eaux territoriales
reconnu par les nations unies et les
turcs navigue dans ces eaux là et même
avant d'aller naviguer dans ces eaux là
quand lorsque la france a voulu faire
des forages avec un consortium qui
inclut et notamment l'egypte la grèce la
turquie s'est portée candidate aussi
elle a dit je veux aussi faire partie de
ce consortium
parce que je sais à proximité de mes
côtes je souhaite aussi en profiter et
la tournée a été immédiatement exclue
donc lorsqu'on dit provocation mais j'ai
envie de dire plutôt réaction certes
elle est comment dire
les propos tenus par le président sont
dures à entendre et je le conçois parce
qu'on est en france et en france on n'a
pas l'habitude de ce langage là mais
encore une fois il faut remettre les
choses dans leur contexte
on parle du moyen-orient et là bas sur
place lorsqu'il ya des propos qui sont
tenus et ben les leaders aussi
fonctionner ainsi et pour répondre à
votre question je vais être assez
conciliant quelques secondes parce qu'on
arrive au terme de cet échange
en quelques secondes et vous conclurez
laurent jacobellis effectivement il fait
aussi comment dire un geste vers ces
versets électeurs puisque c'est un parti
conservateur on est dans un pays
musulman et forcément ça joue on parle
d'un politicien donc de ce côté là oui
il y à aussi à nathalie lessard aussi
un appel à ses soutiens en quelques
secondes laurent jacot belli pour
conclure oui il ne faut pas oublier que
monsieur erdogan est à la tête d'un
parti islamiste et il ne comprend pas
probablement qu'en france il y à ce que
l'on appelle le droit de blasphème ou
droit de caricature mais en appelant en
prétendant pardon en faisant un
parallèle d'ailleurs très douteux avec
la situation des juifs avant la seconde
guerre mondiale en faisant croire que
les musulmans sont maltraitées alors que
nous faisons la lutte contre le
terrorisme
il crée un amalgame lui aussi très
douteux entre musulmans et islamistes
or nous nous faisons bien la part des
choses il y a les français ont d'autres
traductions qui lutte contre le
terrorisme que ça plaise ou non en
matière de gamme merci à tous les deux
d'avoir partager vos points de vue sur
sur cette antenne merci laurent
jacobellis je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du rassemblement national
mercinat n'augure bus vice président de
la chambre de commerce franco turque
des centaines de travailleurs biélorusse
et des étudiants répondent à l'appel
lancé par l'opposante svetlana tirano
sky a désormais installé en lituanie un
mouvement de grève qui fait suite à un
ultimatum pour réclamer une nouvelle
fois le départ du président alexandre
loukachenko avec quelques
interpellations ont eu lieu depuis le
début de la journée
svetlana tirano sky a souhaité faire de
cette grève dans les entreprises
publiques je cite un levier de pression
économique et pour en parler on va tout
de suite retrouvé claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
claude blanchemaison bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
va alors ce lundi marque le début d'un
mouvement de grève pour inciter au
départ du président alexandre
loukachenko
est ce que c'est le début d'un nouveau
bras de fer en tout cas c'est le début
d'une deuxième étape dans un processus
qui est engagée en biélorussie la
première étape est la durée d'une
semaine depuis l'élection contestée du 9
août que monsieur k cecco dit avoir
gagné avec 80 % des voix mais que
l'opposition et que la population
conteste tous les week-ends depuis 12
semaines
la population des fils à minsk et dans
les principales villes de biélorussie
défilent d'ailleurs pacifiquement
puisqu'il ya aucune destruction
aucun incendie de véhicule aucune
destruction de mobilier urbain pour
demander le départ de monsieur
lukashenko alors aujourd'hui à commencer
une deuxième phase qui est la phase la
grève
c'est difficile parce que la grève
générale et quelquefois relève un peu du
mythe
on a constaté aujourd'hui que les
entreprises privées avaient généralement
donné une journée de congé à leurs
salariés que dans les entreprises
privées dans les entreprises publiques
beaucoup de salariés avaient demandé une
journée de congé avait posé un jour de
congé et que dans les entreprises
publiques en gros un quart des salariés
ont fait grève
or les entreprises publiques ça
représente l'immense majorité de
l'économie biélorusse qui n'a pas été
privatisé qui n'a pas été réformé depuis
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
c'est donc une économie néo soviétique
alors je pense que cette grève va
probablement se prolonge et se
renouveler mes dents avec une difficulté
extrême puisque bien sûr le pouvoir à la
possibilité d'agir sur les cadres des
entreprises d'état et également sur les
meneurs dans les ateliers
et dans l'est dans l'ensemble des
entreprises d'état d'ailleurs on a on a
bien vu que hier et aujourd'hui un assez
grand nombre d'arrestations probablement
environ 500 sur les deux journées ont
été pratiquées ceci va continuer
malheureusement pendant sans doute un
certain temps parce que ceci ne suffit
pas à inverser le rapport de force
monsieur le cache un coup à la maîtrise
des but d'aider des forces de police
notamment des forces armées également et
par conséquent ne vois pas pourquoi il
céderait à cette pression qui ne
s'exerce que par des moyens pacifiques
alors quel est le rôle exactement de ce
but la nati ranocchia et bien au
lendemain de l'élection contestée elle a
dit je suis là véritale pour le
président monsieur le cas de celle qu il
n'a pas été élu c'est moi qui ai été élu
aux réalités je crois qu'aujourd'hui
depuis vilnius elle joue un peu le rôle
de ministre des affaires étrangères de
la contestation c'est à dire qu'elle a
sur les relations extérieures de la
contestation
mais le comité de coordination qui est
un comité à ses nombreux dont la plupart
des membres sont à vilnius
quelques-uns en prison d'autres en
liberté ne veut pas de structure purée
ne veut pas de chef et d'ailleurs c'est
l'inde est une des difficultés pour le
gouvernement biélorusse puisque dans le
fond il a beaucoup de mal à trouver des
interlocuteurs il ya huit jours
monsieur le catch écossais livrer à
cette extraordinaire exercice consistant
à les rencontrer des gens qui l'avaient
mis en prison quelques semaines plus tôt
pour discuter avec eux d'une réforme de
la constitution
donc les choses vont durer en attendant
qu'elle se décante et probablement que
en effet moscou regarde ça de très près
merci beaucoup
claude blanche maison pour votre analyse
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales est resté avec
nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la
deuxième vague qui frappe de plein fouet
la france emmanuel macron réunira de
conseil de défense
mardi et mercredi ce qui pourrait
aboutir un dû
si seulement des mesures puis nous
parlerons de la conférence sociale ce
matin à matignon le gouvernement
n'entend pas renoncer sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage à mézin nouveau
report de trois mois de son application
a été acté a tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
et finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois des images assez touchants
de l'armée qui était presque impliqué
avec les manifestants aujourd'hui on
sent que le ton a changé c'est la cause
d un politique et sont en train de
manipuler l'armée on sait très bien
pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus c'est
pas s'ils savent que c'est leur fin ils
se préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence il ne va pas
être violent et on va rester
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu valable moi c'est fini pour moi
est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française la situation sanitaire en
france à présent et un point sur les
derniers chiffres santé publique france
dénombre plus de 2700 malades du commis
de 19 ans hospitalisée en réanimation ce
soir trois cent cinquante sept nouveaux
cas graves ayant été admis dans ses
services au cours des dernières 24
heures un chiffre qui n'avait plus été
atteint depuis avril l'avis du conseil
scientifique concernant le commis de 19
est très clair le président de
l'instance qui conseille l'exécutif jean
françois delfraissy s'est laissé aller à
deux propositions ce lundi sur l'antenne
de rtl à un couvre-feu plus importants
ou un confinement moins dur que celui du
mois de mars
1re confinement qui provoquerait un
écroulement de l'économie selon le
patronat mais jean françois delfraissy
se montre très ferme à la situation
sanitaire est critique
ce virus est très difficile on a acquis
beaucoup d'informations mais on ne
connaît pas tous cette deuxième vague va
être probablement plus forte que la
première dans les trois semaines qui
viennent le retentissement sur le
système de santé va se jouer au niveau
des services de réanimation
je pense que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas
encore pris conscience de ce qui nous
attend je comprends parfaitement que ce
soit quelque chose de difficile à
accepter
et en ce contexte 21 maires du syndicat
intercommunal du pays du gier dans le
sud du département de la loire demande
talent et à l'aide de l'armée pour faire
face aux courants navires us à les
hôpitaux de ce territoire sont fortement
impactées par l'épidémie de kobe de 19
les élus locaux demandent à bénéficier
d'une aide identique à celle qui a été
apporté au printemps dernier à la région
grand est un hôpital de campagne avait
été installé à proximité de l'hôpital
emile muller de mulhouse
regardez
[Musique]
la situation est inquiétante
indiscutablement est très tendue dans
les hôpitaux mais nous la maîtrisons
nous n'en sommes pas à appeler l'armée
car nous faisons face
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors des mères qui appelle l'armée en
renfort
un programme chargé dans les prochaines
heures pour l'exécutif avec un conseil
de défense sanitaire à l'elysée demain
suivi de plusieurs consultations des
membres du gouvernement est la situation
est tendue on revient on y revient tout
de suite avec nos invités et pour en
parler nous sommes avec denis barriol
maire de genilac bonsoir avec vous et
karim khelfaoui médecins généralistes
bonsoir alors donnez barriol on vient de
le voir vous vous réclamez avec 20
autres élus de la loire des moyens
sanitaires militaire le directeur
général de la rs10 comprendre votre
inquiétude mais il assure la situation
est maîtrisée
alors qu'en est-il dans les hôpitaux de
votre région quels sont les remontées
que vous vous avez beaucoup d'inquiétude
avec mes collègues de la vallée du gier
sont dans sa tt métropole donc ça fait
plusieurs jours maintenant en attendant
des chiffres inquiétants et négatifs que
qu'au niveau national
beaucoup ont relayé et nous apprenons
que la belle et du gic et on peut
regretter une commune qui font partie de
cette métropole sont particulièrement
touchés pas forcément il ya une
inquiétude très forte des mers et lors
de notre dernière réunion du comité
syndical cette inquiétude a fait naître
l'idée d'un courrier à l'état pour
demander des moyens supplémentaires
notre idée en fait c'est d'anticiper ne
s'est pas la gestion d'aujourd'hui même
si on sait qu'elle est tendue qu'elle
est complexe
c'était pour anticiper un besoin besoins
à venir c'est une démarche très positive
inclinés par la critique
on est vraiment dans l'anticipation
justement à propos d' anticipation karim
khelfaoui
appel que vous êtes médecin généraliste
par rapport vous à ce que vous observez
la question d'un reconfirmant
aujourd'hui on n'a plus le choix
aujourd'hui on se retrouve au pied du
mur puisque ça fait six mois que le
gouvernement avait tout le temps pour
préparer une deuxième vague mais qu'ils
n'ont absolument rien de préparé et en
partie civile n'aurait absolument pas
préparés l'aval c'est-à-dire que se sont
concentrées sur l'amour le fait de d'une
manière un peu prétentieuse de dire
qu'ils avaient suffisamment casser les
chaînes de contamination avec le système
de traçage qu'ils allaient limiter les
contaminations avec des mesures
liberticides qu'on a vu dans les bars
les restos les couvre feux etc
on voit qu absolument rien n'a marché
puisque en réalité n'ont aucune prise
sur les contaminations elle-même a
priori parce que déjà ils ne s'occupent
pas des contaminations qui se passe en
lien avec le travail à l'école dans les
entreprises ou dans les universités ou
dans les transports en commun il fait de
ne pas voir le problème fn et de rejeter
la faute sur les français et aujourd'hui
ils n'ont pas préparé la vallée on a un
premier ministre qui nous dit que ce qui
soulagerait l'hôpital
finalement ce serait de ne pas tomber
malade mais de qui on se moque
aujourd'hui en vérité c'était à eux de
préparer sa de renforcer l'hôpital
on a un président de la république qui
au mois de juillet nous a expliqué que
l'hôpital était prêt pour une deuxième
vague et on se rend compte à quel point
c'est absolument faux encore une fois
parce qu'il fallait un plan d'embauchés
massives
il ne suffisait pas de dire on va
augmenter de 130 euros les salaires 1140
euros c'était pas ça qui compte
c'était une un plan d'embauchés massives
et aujourd'hui il monte à nouveau en
disant qu'il n'y a pas les compétences
dans le pays qu'il n'ya pas les enfants
nés alors qu'en réalité ne serait ce que
pour les infirmiers il y en a plus de
150000 qui sont dans des missions
d'intérim ou de remplacement et qui ne
veulent plus aller à l'hôpital à cause
des conditions de travail donc c'était
là dessus qu'il fallait le faire et
aujourd'hui angie on ne veut pas que les
gens on nous l on a justifié péter
mesures liberticides en dix ans mais
nous ne voulons pas nous ne voulons pas
que les gens et en réanimation mais moi
non plus je veux pas qu'ils aillent en
réanimation mais la réalité il faut
faire avec c'est qu'ils y vont quand
même quand il le veut dire qu'ils sont
malades
moi non plus je veux pas qu'elle guerre
dans le monde je veux qu'on éradique a
peu voté et j'aimerais avoir un
gouvernement compétent mais il faut
faire avec un principe de réalité il
fallait augmenter les lits et ça fait
des mois qu'il fallait le faire
aujourd'hui on paye le prix de ce qu'ils
ont pas fait justement denis barriol on
entend la colère du docteur qu'elle
fabrique vous rejoignez un petit peu ce
que ce qu'on vient d'entendre c'est à
dire ce manque dans tipi d'anticipation
finalement avant cette seconde vague qui
arrive pas exactement si je ne partage
pas par exemple l'idée des mesures
liberticides vote parce qu'on avait on a
besoin de prendre les mesures en fait le
tour des marchés elle est complémentaire
à celle de l'état simplement en fait les
deux logiques et non pas une seule
logique
je me souviens très bien lors de la
réunion la venue a été une quarantaine
de lui autour de la table il n'y a pas
que les mères qui était présent et notre
notre action notre démarche auprès de
madame la préfète était double il avait
certes c'est inquiétudes très fortes qui
remonte du terrain et j'ai besoin de
d'anticipation qui nous paraissait
absolument nécessaire par rapport à
l'inquiétude que l'état lui même
d'ailleurs fait peser aussi sur le sur
les élus et une saignée logique avec les
chiffres qui tombent régulièrement mais
en même temps pour se situer une partie
la population en tout cas nous en notre
vallée qui n'avait pas conscience
qu'elles étaient particulièrement
touchés et je pense qu'on s'est rendu
compte mais un décalage entre les
informations que nous pouvions la bois
et les informations qu une partie de la
population pouvait le connaître et le
fait d'avoir le fait d'être à table ou
b2b d'être avec vous ce soir par exemple
c'est aussi peut-être une des logiques
en tout cas pour chercher à avoir été
bercé reprendre confiance en notre
peuple sur le transilien
il a opposé les deux logiques passionnel
de son uranium
j'en fasse attention il faut qu'on
anticipe le moyen vous vous préparez à
quoi ce soir très concrètement est-ce
que vous anticipez des mesures qui
pourraient être prendre dans les
prochaines heures dans les prochains
jours alors nous les communes les
batailles communes n'étaient pas
entraînement d'un relier à nouveau avec
une information qui sont travaillés
puisqu'on a des tailles de communes qui
sont là aussi de très petites atteint
très grande donc on a des moyens
différents mais on a nous relier des
vêtements c'est avec nos moyens
c'est ce message d'inquiétude d'une part
pour le reste je dirais que ont fait que
ça depuis mars que sont le maire depuis
mars
ils s'adaptent ils essaient de
stabiliser une situation qui est
instable par essence mais pour la
population on essaie de leur donner des
repères alors pour une semaine ou quinze
jours ont fait que ça donc on saura
faire demain s'il ya de nouvelles
décisions qui sont prises on gère cette
angoisse on gère cette instabilité
depuis mars et c'est en tout cas qu'on
est complémentaire avec les textes
composant la vie montée des mers contre
l'état de travailler ensemble
docteur comment comprendre la violence
de cette seconde vague est ce qu'elle
aurait pu être anticipé quels sont les
facteurs finalement qui ont favorisé ce
fort rebond de l'épidémie les chiffres
on le voit ont bondi ces derniers jours
est ce qu'elles auraient pu être
anticipés oui c'est évident de nombreux
scientifiques épidémiologistes mettait
en garde de déconfinement contre cette
seconde vague est en réalité on a un
impact
on a fait comme si tout allait bien
parce qu'il y avait moins de
contamination parce que le vieux
circuler dans une population plus jeune
et je suis d'accord avec monsieur le
maire il faut que la population et les
conscience du danger
mais en réalité les français ils ont ils
n'ont fait que ce que le gouvernement
leur a permis de faire c'est le cadre
général
l'environnement dans lequel on a évolué
a été décidée par le gouvernement
et aujourd'hui on paie encore une fois
le manque d'anticipation et ce que je
voulais dire c'est que le ne pas
s'attaquer aux contaminations qui ont
nui au travail et c'était une immense
faute qu'on paie aujourd'hui parce que
deux contaminations qui était au départ
chez les plus jeunes dans l'été on a
très vite disséminés cette contamination
dans d'autres tranches d'âge parce que
les gens ne sont pas rencontrés que dans
lé cadre privé sinon on aurait vu les
effets des mesures qui ont été prises
sur les bars les restos les salles de
sport et les couvre feu mais il y en a
aucun c'est bien que au départ il y
avait un problème avec des
contaminations au travail notamment à
l'école et pendant la pâque tenu compte
le gouvernement a fait comme si ça
n'existait pas et a même expliqué aux
français que c'était en réalité le soir
quand il était fatigué et qu'il baisser
leur vigilance qui se contaminent et ce
qui est complètement faux
c'est encore une fois à mon sens est en
réalité il le savait parce que la seule
donnée qu'on avait sur les lieux de
contamination
c'était celle de santé publique france
sur les clusters et on sait que la
majorité se faisait au travail met en
lien avec le travail et le gouvernement
a fait comme si ça n'existait pas parce
qu'ils disaient les clusters ça ne
concerne que 10 % des contaminations
donc ils sont partis du principe que les
90% restants n'avait rien à voir
alors qu'en réalité on
mais aucun argument scientifique pour
dire que les quatre les contaminations
restantes se faisait dans des lieux qui
était différent par rapport aux clusters
denis barriol aujourd'hui est ce que
vous êtes favorable à de nouvelles
mesures quitte à ce qu'elle soit lé dur
pour vos administrés qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez vous aujourd'hui pour juguler
cette cette contamination et faire face
à l'afflux de patients dans les hôpitaux
alors quand on pose ce genre de
questions généralement j'ai coutume de
dire que je ne suis pas médecin donc je
n'ai pas la compétence on sera les
mesures avec les terres qui pourraient
être prises je ne suis pas spécialiste
mais ces questions moi ce que je dirai
que nous on doit nous élus à la fois ça
passe et des informations qui nous sont
donnés faire en sorte qu'on puisse les
décliner sur le talent pour qu'elle soit
comprise par la population
sécuriser au mieux les process parce que
c'est pas évident du tout du tout pour
la population et le fait de danty cité
par contre et c'était ça l'objet d'un
contrôle du courrier qu'on a on avait
l'impression qu'on te demander des
moyens pour la population après ce qui
va devoir à nouveau rapidement s'il ne
faut pas honnêtement je ne sais pas où
on sera prêt de toute façon pour la
batterie en de messages auprès de notre
population ça c'est sûr des rôles fait
depuis marque en fait le gouvernement
monsieur vers le gouvernement c'est vrai
que disait communiqué en disant voilà on
va s'appuyer sur les acteurs de terrain
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya un vrai
dialogue entre l'exécutif et vous
acteurs du terrain est-ce que cela la
chaîne fonctionne bien de communication
on a des informations aussi une nouvelle
fois fait un gros effort aussi pourquoi
voir comment une commune question ça je
reconnais ceci dit on voit là on ya peu
donne peu de la formation remonte on
s'attendait plutôt dans la déclinaison
d'éléments qui sont qui sont qui nous
sont tous ont demandé françois sepa team
je ne sais pas ce qui me gêne parce que
c'est aussi comme ça que loeb se faire
les choses dans un cas les temps par
contre il ne faut pas qu'on oublie
seulement il cessa modifier énormément
paccolo 10 de ce mois passant les
chiffres sont très graves attention les
courbes sur l'expérience yale attention
dans votre territoire est encore pire
que de la métropole n'a par contre on va
essayer ça pendant quatre semaines
pendant six semaines
c'est pas possible de reporter certains
ouest
tâche aux élus locaux on est là pour
organiser pour être positif mais on ne
peut pas porter une angoisse qu qu'il
n'y a pas derrière dont il ya
exceptionnel si on vous dit tous les
jours que la situation qui nous est
exceptionnel docteur khalfaoui le
gouvernement avait misé 1 sur sa
stratégie des tests avec ce fameux
triptyque tester isolé tracé pourquoi
selon vous et bien ça n'a pas permis de
juguler la propagation du coronavirus
pour plusieurs raisons et elles sont
trois en fait on allie tester
correctement ni isoler correctement ni
tracé correctement et en réalité la
politique de traçage était vouée à
l'échec depuis le départ on a testé de
manière absolument chaotique depuis le
début et la seule variable en fait qui
intéressait le gouvernement c'est de
pouvoir dire regardez en fait de plus en
plus de tests et sa fabuleuse c'était le
la variable qui nous donnait à chaque
fois ont fait plus d'un million test par
semaine mais c'était pas ça qu'il
fallait faire c'était en réalité testé
dans les zones où il y avait une forte
densité de population où le virus
circule et fortement dans les eaux dans
les écoles de sacy reculé fortement dans
les endroits où ça circule et fortement
fallait cibler il fallait cibler et par
contre à chaque fois ne pas attendre
justement qu'on est impatient et qu'on
ait le temps de faire un traçage qui
prenaient du temps parce qu'il fallait
qu'il aille voir le médecin parce qu il
fallait qu ensuite l'assurance maladie
le contact etc etc
mais en réalité dès qu'il y en avait un
cas positif avec des cas positifs à des
endroits là il fallait engager un
dépistage de masse dans ce lieu un
dépistage de masse ce n'est pas comme je
n'ai entendu de la bouche du ministre on
va tester toute la population tout le
temps c'est on va déguster à chaque fois
qu'il ya des endroits où c'est
intéressant de le faire toute la
population concernée c'est ça qu'il
fallait faire le traçage c'est pareil on
nous a fait du tort un cinéma sur ce
traçage en réalité même le conseil
constitutionnel
effectivement ça c'était une atteinte à
nos libertés individuelles et au secret
médical et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
avec une situation où en réalité dans
75% des cas on n'arrive pas à relier un
cas à un autre donc voilà il pas trace t
on n'arrive pas à remonter les chefs de
contamination et l'isolément
il n'a jamais été quelque chose
d'obligatoire
c'est à dire plein de plaisir où on a
décidé que mais on a les réquisitionner
des hôtels et on allait effectivement
d'isoler les malades
là c'est pas le cas là elle était en
larmes on a compté sur le fait que les
gens allaient le faire ce qui est on
peut compter sur eux parce qu'ils sont
quand même intelligent mais en dehors de
ça et qu'ils ont continué à contaminer
leurs familles leurs foyers qui des fois
on n'avait pas toutes les informations
dont on continue à sortir dé continuer
continue à contaminer du monde
donc en réalité le fameux tester isolé
tracé n'a jamais été réellement restait
interdite donc voila merci docteur karim
khelfaoui je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste
merci à vous également denis barriol
maire de génilac merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
maintenant quelles conséquences cette
crise sanitaire aura-t-elle sur
l'économie du pays
la question était justement au centre
des discussions à matignon ce matin une
conférence sociale en présence de jean
castex du ministre de l'économie et de
la ministre du travail ainsi que des
représentants syndicaux et du patronat
la réforme de l'assurance chômage a été
évoquée le gouvernement n'entend pas
renoncer mais un nouveau report de trois
mois de son application a été actée
écoutez le premier ministre à ce sujet
plus que jamais le dialogue concertation
sont indispensables ils le sont toujours
ils le sont particulièrement dans les
circonstances très grave que traverse
notre pays
j'ai annoncé aux partenaires sociaux
compte tenu de l'aggravation de la crise
sanitaire économique et social un
nouveau report de trois mois de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage tout en
leur indiquant clairement que le
gouvernement n'entendent pas renoncer à
cette réforme match
heures pas plus qu'à toutes les autres
réformes qui ont pour objectif de
transformer de moderniser notre pays de
le rendre plus fort et plus juste une
réunion empreinte de gravité selon les
syndicats ces derniers redoutent tard
confinement dur qui menacerait un peu
plus l'économie du pays et coûté le
tissu des entreprises tous secteurs mais
en particulier dans certains secteurs
est extrêmement fragilisée alors qu'en
mars les entreprises étaient en très
bonne santé en était on l'a oublié mais
en pleine croissance baisse du chômage
croissance économique
donc si je prends une comparaison
médical des mesures de confinement dur
aurait pas du tout les mêmes
conséquences cette réunion elle a été
empreinte d'une certaine gravité liées à
la situation
maintenant la décision de des mesures
sanitaires supplémentaires nous incombe
pas à nous on a redit les uns et les
autres ce qu'étaient nos nos conditions
de protection parce que que ce soit des
entreprises pour les arrivées sont
patronales mais aussi la blessure
cervicales parce que la situation des
entreprises nous incombe que la
situation des salariés en tant que tel
et maintenant la décision sera à prendre
parce qu'ils sont là pour ça nous avons
insisté pour que le gouvernement mette
la pression si je puis dire en
augmentant le smic
le gouvernement a les moyens rapidement
de faire en sorte que ces deuxièmes
lignes comme il les appelle soient
augmentées rapidement alors on le disait
le gouvernement qui n'entend pas
renoncer à la réforme de l'assurance
chômage tandis que de vives inquiétudes
sont dans tous les esprits sur la
situation économique
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'éditorialiste alexis poulain
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
nouveau report de l'application de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
ah mais aucun abandon prévu comme le
réclament les responsables des cinq
centrales syndicales
l état a droit dans ses bottes l'état
fou l'état totalement qui a perdu pied
je crois que c'est ridicule de vouloir
continuer dans ces réformes d'un autre
temps regardez ce qu'il se passe ce
virus ne finit pas maintenant il est
question peut-être d'un possible
confinement nous avons un couvre-feu
l'économie ne va pas se relever
l'économie mondiale est entrée dans une
zone de turbulences pour des mois
peut-être des années des secteurs
entiers vont s'effondrer et vous avez ce
gouvernement qui fait comme tout comme
si tout allait bien madame la marquise
et comme si seulement trois mois de
délai de cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage allait suffire à éviter le pire
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage si
jamais elle devait avoir lieu elle
précipiterait dans la précarité
un nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
stratosphérique comparé à ce qui est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui si le gouvernement était un
gouvernement qui gère qui prévoit qui
est aux commandes et qui a un plan
stratégique alors il devrait penser à
comment lutter contre la précarité qui
va exploser dans les mois qui viennent
comment faire pour que des millions de
français ne connaissent pas ni la faim
ni la pauvreté sachant que l'emploi va
se faire rare or vous avez là des gens
et je ne comprends pas qu'ils sont assis
autour d'une table et qu'ils discutent
du monde d'hier comme si tout allait
continuer sur des réformes qui n'ont
plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui s'il ya une
chose à faire avec cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage c'est de prendre le
papier c'est de le mettre dans la
machine à recycler essaie de récupérer
le papier pour faire quelque chose
d'autre avec mais certainement pas de
dire qu'on va décaler de trois mois ces
mesures qui de toute façon ne servent
plus à rien aujourd'hui
et pourtant il continue et ils sortent
et je crois que si les partenaires
sociaux utiliser ce temps utile
maintenant à planifier la praye qu'ovide
la suite des opérations dans une
économie de basse intensité de base
croissance dans une économie incertaine
où les frontières vont se fermer ou les
échanges ne seront plus jamais comme
avant
alors il faut penser à comment sauver
les travailleurs français comment faire
que en
une période de faible intensité on n'est
pas toute une génération qui sombre dans
le chômage et dans le chômage
sans aide c'est parce que c'est ça la
réforme de l'assurance chômage c'est de
dire simplement vous allez être formés
pendant quelques mois et puis après vous
trouverez du travail mais il y en aura
plus du travail
si on regarde ce qui se passe c'est bien
simple les entrepreneurs ceux qui ont
des bars des restaurants le monde de la
nuit
même dans le voyage le spectacle etc
combien d'entreprises vont fermer vont
mettre la clé sous la porte
eh bien on a l'impression encore une
fois que le gouvernement ne prévoit rien
du tout et continue sa feuille de route
qui n'a plus aucun sens aujourd'hui plus
aucun sens aujourd'hui et
malheureusement jean castex fait comme
si tout allait bien jean castex je le
rappelle
c'était monsieur déconfinement qui avait
filé les clés du déconfinement au
cabinet de conseil bain and company on a
vu le succès on est en pleine deuxième
vague
c'est une catastrophe l'école rien n'est
prévu pour la rentrée après les vacances
scolaires et tout est à l'envi et cette
conférence sociale elle est surréaliste
on a des gens autour d'une table qui
discutent comme si le monde allait
normalement comme si rien n'avait changé
depuis cette crise sanitaire qui a tout
changé
est ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
c'est parler de revenu universel c'est
voir comment on va éviter que les soupes
populaires soient débordés dans les mois
qui viennent comment on va faire pour
que les entreprises ne mettent pas
massivement la clé sous la porte
or aujourd'hui le plan de relance qui
est sur la table ne prévoit que 0,8 pour
cent de la somme totale des milliards
totaux pour lutter contre la précarité
et l'extrême pauvreté rien hélas rien
n'a été discutées à la conférence
sociale à part peut-être la cgt qui
demandent l'augmentation du smic mais
encore une fois ce gouvernement refuse
d'augmenter les minima sociaux
parce que ça éviterait que le retour à
l'emploi de certaines personnes qui
préférait prendre les minima sociaux
mais on n'est plus dans ce monde là on
n'est plus dans le plein emploi depuis
longtemps
or il continue de faire croire que ce
monde-là va continuer c'est incroyable
de voir cette hypocrisie
ce déni de réel de la part des
dirigeants politiques qui sont là pour
prévoir alors il ya aussi à une fois de
plus la réforme des retraites
aucun abandon non plus elle doit revenir
dans le débat fin 2001 débile 21 mai où
sera ton finalement à ce moment là c'est
un nouveau brûlot en perspective
finalement non encore une fois cette
réforme des retraites anachronique qui
doit elle aussi être mis dans la machine
à recycler le papier c'est fini on n'en
parle plus et pourtant cette réforme des
retraites si on continue
dw attaques liées à la croissance lll
est fait sur l'optimisme sur le fait que
l'économie va créer des richesses et sur
le fait qu'on va pouvoir faire de
l'argent avec de l'argent
alors oui ça marche pour les
milliardaires comme jeff bezos ce pour
certains fonds de pension sans doute
comme blackrock et autres qui profitent
de cette crise pour faire un maximum
d'argent avant que on ferme le cinéma et
que tout le monde s'en aille mais ça ne
va pas durer
la réforme des retraites encore une fois
c'est quelque chose qui est dangereux si
on l'a fait en l'état actuel c'est
simplement dire à des générations
entières qu'elles n'auront plus de
retraite et qu'elles travailleront
jusqu'à la mort et là encore que fait le
gouvernement est bien il veut continuer
ses réformes
cette feuille de route alors que même un
pays comme la grande bretagne qui a
inventé le thatchérisme est en train de
mettre le thatchérisme à la poubelle
avec des lois sociales pour essayer
d'éviter le pire à ses travailleurs et
qui a commencé déjà à quitter l'europe
et à fermer les frontières en comprenant
bien que le la donne du monde avait
changé mais aujourd'hui à la tête de
l'état on a des gens qui ne comprennent
rien à ce qui se passe et qui sont
complètement largué excusez moi du terme
et qui n'ont aucune aucune mais vision
stratégique de ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour prévenir et pour sauver l'avenir de
ce pays parce que c'est pas en
continuant à faire des réformes
d'inspiration néolibérale qu'on va
sauver l'avenir de ce pays maintenant
c'est la solidarité qui doit primer
c'est aller chercher l'argent là où il
est quand il sert à rien dans la sphère
financière et éviter que des millions de
concitoyens rentrer dans l'extrême
pauvreté
or encore une fois hypocrisie discours
vide quand on écoute jean castex on est
sidéré en fait de ce vide intersidéral
où ils nous présentent des réformes qui
n'ont plus lieu d'être comme si c'était
la feuille de route qu'il fallait
continuer moi j'ai peur je pense que de
nombreux français ne comprennent plus ce
qui se passe en haut il faudrait
peut-être commencer à à se poser des
vraies questions notamment vis-à-vis des
partenaires sociaux je suis étonné de la
part de la cgt ou de la cfdt
qu'il se soit assis autour de cette
table qu'il soit resté et qu'il n'est
pas claqué la porte en disant mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait là qu'est ce qu'on
fait là je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une crise sanitaire qui mérite un peu de
un peu plus de hauteur et un peu plus de
réflexion stratégique que cette
conférence sociale que nous avons vu
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes
est resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous partirons aux états unis
retrouvé notre envoyé spécial stéphanie
hu à washington qui suit pour nous elle
la campagne présidentielle a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense en europe et tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs sec
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet et 10 juillet les menaces sur
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus dit libre haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu
des divergences avec l europe pour nous
le faire
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
était assez violente d'ailleurs entre
les russes et les américains alors que
j'étais destinée à voler avec les russes
mais une opportunité s'est ouverte de
faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens dimanche voyez
aussi tôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout ça on le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de notre planète
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple accepter
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on s'en doute est il est
clair que tout le monde attend ça est-ce
que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens ne s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
tiacoh politique a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 26 octobre 2020 j - 8 avant
l'élection présidentielle aux états unis
et les américains se déplacent en nombre
pour participer au vote anticipé 60
millions de votes déjà recensés dans le
pays
la cour suprême devrait voir l l'entrée
d'amico neil barrett une magistrate
conservatrice choisi par donald trump
après le feu vert du sénat tous les
jours dans cette émission nous
retrouvons stéphanie de murs eu notre
envoyé spécial à washington elle suit
pour nous cette campagne dans le
haut-karabagh les combats se poursuivent
malgré la médiation américaine intervenu
après deux cessez le feu sous l'égide de
moscou rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter le
conflit l'aurait déjà fait 5000 morts
selon le président russe vladimir
poutine et des dizaines de milliers de
déplacés
arménie et azerbaïdjan une paix est
impossible c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
le coronavirus qui bouscule les agendas
emmanuel macron réunira de conseil de
défense mardi et mercredi
jean castex consultera lui les forces
politiques et les partenaires sociaux
alors que le virus circule de manière
extrêmement rapide sur le territoire est
l'hypothèse d'un nouveau confinement est
sur la table face à une deuxième vague
le site brutale qui pourrait même être
plus forte que la première avertit le
professeur delfraissy président du
conseil scientifique
nous ne devons pas baisser les bras dans
la lutte contre la pandémie exhorte le
chef de l' oms le virus toujours qui
progresse en espagne face à une
situation sanitaire juger je cite
extrême
le premier ministre pedro sanchez a
annoncé l'instauration d'un état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'à début mai et
d'un couvre feu dans tout le pays de 23h
à 6h à l'exception des îles canaries où
l'incidence du virus est faible
il s'agit du deuxième état d'urgence
décrété en espagne après celui instauré
en mars pour contrer la première vague
et qui avait duré jusqu'en juin
et direction les états unis tout de
suite à huit jours de l'élection
présidentielle nous retrouvons un autre
envoyé spécial stéphanie de mur lui
[Musique]
bonjour stéphanie est très heureux de
vous retrouver depuis washington
alors le sénat bonjour olivier alors le
sénat devrait donner le feu vert dans la
soirée à la nomination de la juge amy
connaît bar est absolument olivier sans
surprise les effets de sénateurs
devraient confirmer la nomination de
cette mère de sept enfants âgée de 48
ans de juge à la cour suprême au
fauteuil laissé vacant vous le savez par
ruth bader ginsburg décédé en septembre
dernier une simple formalité compte tenu
de la majorité républicaine ci dément ya
du vent washington à chaque chronique
vous l'avez remarqué 53 sièges pour les
républicains contre sens dans cette
enceinte
hier il faut savoir que la candidate de
trump a déjà obtenu 51 voix sur 48
un seul un sénateur il faut le préciser
républicains étaient toujours réticents
à donner sa voix quelques semaines de la
présidentielle
il faut dire que l'enjeu est
considérable
ce nom donald trump lui même nommé un
juge suprême à la cour et la décision la
plus importante que peut faire un
président américain
rien de rien que cela en tout cas donald
trump ne s'en est pas privé puisqu'il a
déjà renouvelé un tiers de la cour
suprême avec six juges conservateurs sur
neuf ça fait beaucoup
alors pourquoi est-ce aussi important et
bien parce que cette nouvelle juge avec
ses comparses aura pour mission de se
prononcer sur des sujets sociaux aussi
important par exemple que le
l'avortement on sait qu'elle est très
conservatrice 1 je le répète le mariage
homosexuel ou l'assurance santé
justement l'obamacare qui sera débattue
à la cour suprême
précisément à partir du 10 novembre et
c'est précisément ce qui inquiète
beaucoup les démocrates qui crient au
vol et qui sont très inquiets et écouté
elizabeth warren il y à 37 dure
également mitch mcconnell avait déclaré
qu' ligne
le soin le plus fervent de ruth bader
ginsburg et engagerait la procédure
viciée et illégitime visant à combler
son poste à la cour suprême
oui jours à peine huit jours avant
l'élection
alors que des dizaines de millions
d'américains ont déjà voté et seulement
15 jours avant que la cour suprême
étudie un cas qui pourrait infirmer la
fois des bols qu'un acte donald trump
mitch mcconnell et leurs comparses et
parti républicain
pas fous les souhaits du peuple
américain afin d'usurper ce siège à la
cour suprême
alors il n'ya pas l'obamacare il ya un
autre sujet qui est sur toutes les
lèvres et pour cause c'est l'élection
présidentielle elle-même vous le savez
vous l'avais dit à olivier tout à
l'heure près de 60 millions d'américains
ont déjà voté par correspondance
certainement raison de la pandémie et
donald trump lui met régulièrement en
garde contre justement une élection
truquée en cas d'invalidité le président
américain déjà déclaré qu'il
souhaiterait que les juges de la cour
suprême et leur mot à dire étrange
justement les questions litigieuses et
at il précisé que la cour la juge bar
est justement soit en première ligne sur
ces sujets le chef de file des
républicains au sénat lui tient à
relativiser et préfère retenir les
compétences de la nouvelle juge pour
nous assurer le maintien de la
séparation des pouvoirs
garantir les droits des citoyens il nous
faut pour voir nos tribunaux avec des
personnes de très grande qualité
c'est une grande chance pour notre pays
que le sénat viennent de confirmer l'une
des candidates les plus qualifiés de
cette génération pour le service
judiciaire la juge amy koné barrettes de
la cour d'appel américaine du 7e ressort
est une candidate exceptionnelle sous
tous les aspects mais c'est tout aussi
important
madame barrette a fait preuve de son
refus absolu d'imposer ses opinions
personnelles
ou de bricoler de nouvelles politiques à
coups de décision de justice elle a
manifesté l'humilité devant la loi la
neutralité et la loyauté à notre
constitution qui sont essentiels pour ce
poste est à noter que my peine 100 le
vice président devait normalement un
présider cette séance de vote final ce
soit mais les sénateurs démocrates
l'oignon expressément demandé de
s'abstenir parce que figurez-vous que
cinq proches collaborateurs de ce vice
présidents ont été testés positifs aux
convives 19
alors en attendant stéphanie la campagne
se poursuit sur le terrain bien sûr mais
évidemment aussi dans les médias
stéphanie ah oui vous savez les médias
c'est très important ici et ça ne manque
pas quotidiennement d'anecdotes
croustillantes il faut fouiller pour
faire le tri dernière petite anecdote de
campagne joe biden qui lors d'une
interview à la chaîne nbc diffusé ce
lundi a confondu son adversaire donald
trump avec un certain georges et côté
qu'elle sorte deux pays voulons nous
être quatre années supplémentaires de
george george nous allons nous retrouver
dans une situation où si donald trump
est élu nous serons dans un monde
fondamentalement différent voilà une
petite bourde qui est finalement passé
assez inaperçu ici aux etats-unis on
avait beau scruter et bbc cnn ou si
biais c'est bien aucune allusion à cette
bourde de joe biden ce que n'a pas
manqué évidemment de remarquer à donald
trump qui en a profité
comme à son habitude pour critiquer les
médias mainstream joe biden m'a appelé
georges hier il ne se souvenait pas de
mon nom il a reçu de l'aide du
présentateur pour réussir l'interview
le cartel des fausses nouvelles fait des
heures supplémentaires pour le couvrir
et la campagne vous l'avez dit olivier
qui se poursuit bien évidemment sur le
terrain enfin surtout il
bien le dire pour donald trump qui a
aujourd'hui tenues pas moins de trois
meetings deux dans l'état clé de la
pennsylvanie et un autre en virginie
occidentale quant à joe biden et bien
rien pour le moment en tout cas rien
pour aujourd'hui à son agenda c'est la
même chose d'ailleurs pour sa colistière
kamala harris met à joe biden a prévu de
se rendre en floride cette semaine
merci beaucoup stéphanie nous faire
vivre au plus près du terrain cette
campagne et nous nous retrouvons bien
entendu dans nos prochaines émissions
pour continuer à suivre avec vous
l'élection présidentielle américaine
[Musique]
conclu à washington le troisième cessez
le feu négocié ce mois ci pour stopper
les combats dans le haut karabagh est un
nouvel échec
comme pour les précédentes trêves chaque
parties s'accusent mutuellement de
violer l'accord les précisions avec
grégoire doucet lé cessez le feu se
suivent mais ne s'applique toujours pas
dans la région contestée du haut
karabagh alors que les combats ont
repris intensément depuis un mois
cette nouvelle tentative se révèle à
nouveau infructueuses autorités azéries
et arméniennes se rejettent mutuellement
la responsabilité de cet échec
un scénario qui se répète inlassablement
depuis le 17 octobre une trêve a été
instaurée
mais deux minutes après l'arménie l'a
rompu aujourd'hui à 8 heures du matin
une nouvelle proposition concernant une
trêve humanitaire a été fait mais à 9
heures elle a de nouveau été rompu par
la partie arménienne qui a bombardé la
région de tartares pourtant j'ai donné
pour instruction aux forces armées de
l'azerbaïdjan d'éviter toute provocation
et de ne pas répondre aux violations du
régime de cessez le feu par l'arménie
l'arménie continue de respecter
strictement le régime de cessez le feu
la russie qui copréside le groupe de
minsk chargé de participer à la
résolution du conflit appelle chaque
parti à se mobiliser pour la paix le
règlement de la crise dans le
haut-karabagh qui traverse une période
difficile ne doit et ne peut pas donner
lieu à une rivalité ou à une concurrence
bien entendu la russie en tant que
coprésidents du groupe de minsk y est
prête à saluer toute mesure contribuant
à mettre fin à la guerre
faute de solution pacifique pour le
moment des médiateurs du groupe de minsk
qui doivent rencontrer les chefs de la
diplomatie azérie arménienne ce jeudi à
genève un mois après le début du conflit
dans le haut-karabagh à les combats ne
cessent de s'intensifier entre
azerbaïdjanais arménien on le disait un
troisième cessez le feu négocié ce week
end a été rompu quelques minutes après
son instauration ce matin à d'une autre
question ce soir arménien azerbaïdjanais
elle appelle vraiment possible là c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec françois
devedjian avocat bonsoir c'est vous qui
avez fait voter par le parlement la
reconnaissance du génocide arménien à à
vos côtés dil badie gasimov docteur en
droit international bonsoir merci
messieurs d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors un troisième cessez le
feu qui n'est pas qu'ils ne respectaient
par aucun des partis notre question est
sans doute celle que beaucoup de monde
se pose les arméniens
est ce qu'ils veulent vraiment la paix
aujourd'hui françois deweille jean ah
bah oui salle et arméniens il ya aucun
doute sur le fait qu'ils veulent la paix
ils veulent deux choses
ils veulent la paix et la paix sur leur
terre ils sont prêts à beaucoup je pense
pour obtenir cette paix ne sont pas eux
qui ont des contenus qui ont déclenché
ce conflit et ce ne sont pas eux qui
violent le cessez le feu comme le
constate tous les journalistes
indépendants ils sont sur place et qu'on
se tient dépendance est évidemment ceux
qui se trouvent dans des pays où la
liberté de la presse est permise même
question pour vous dit baby asimov
les hasards les azerbaijan a dopé par le
soutien turc est ce qu'ils veulent
vraiment la fin de ce conflit aussi
finalement écouté les airs visionner
bien sûr qu'ils veulent la fin de ce
conflit sachez que lazard veillon
aujourd'hui c'est les engagés dans une
guerre ce n'est pas par le plaisir de
faire la guerre lazare région il faut
savoir que une personne sur dix un
hasard bedian d'aujourd'hui à savoir un
total d'un million de personnes qui sont
chassés par leur coeur et qui habite
tente des conditions abominables
la recette tirée en vrai problème pour
les arv et jean lasar régence persuade
que que ce soit le plus préservé j'en ai
vu que le gouvernement n'a que cinq
heures soit réglé au plus tôt même
aujourd'hui je monsieur président aliev
il a encore répété énième fois
aujourd'hui que le jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est l'arménie s'engage à libérer les
territoires occupés et qui s'engage à
négocier sur le statut de haut car à
voir lazare oisiens s'engage à arrêter
aujourd'hui les opérations militaires
alors la trêve devait donc commencé ce
matin à 6 heures les deux camps ont
chacun très rapidement dénoncé une
violation grossière du cessez le feu
trêve négociée âprement à washington
après celle de moscou on disait il ya
quelques jours
est ce qu'il ya une solution
diplomatique possible pour les arméniens
françois devedjian et par où cela
pourrait passer pour vous écouter et je
souhaite de toute façon qu'il y ait une
solution diplomatique
la solution diplomatique pour les
arméniens elle est relativement simple
la pac qui est le nom arméniens du
karabagh et arméniens depuis au moins le
1er siècle avant jésus-christ il l'a
toujours été
il y a eu des minorités notamment
avaient ri pendant la période soviétique
en particulier pour ne pas remonter trop
loin mais de l'ordre de 5 10 squat est
monté jusqu'à 12 13% de la population se
sucrent sur la pac et toutes les séries
je reviendrai pas sur l'histoire mais de
de ce référendum prise par la population
d'arsac qui demandait 3 pour attachement
à l'arménie soit son indépendance est
donc la solution pour les arméniens de
l'artac elle est très simple elle est
aujourd'hui de vivre librement sur leur
terre le droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes et de permettre
effectivement il ya une partie
aujourd'hui les territoires on va dire
contesté qui sont qui ne sont pas en
arsac son larzac étant une partie de la
montagne toute la partie de la plaine
n'est pas la pac et
les arméniens n'ont aucune revendication
sur sur ces zones là je mettrais de par
exception le couloir de la tune qui lui
est dans la montagne est une vraie
arménienne et et voilà c'est une
solution qui permettrait à chacun de
vivre chez lui et peut-être d'apprendre
à mieux se connaître et à pouvoir avoir
des relations qu'ils ne soient plus des
relations de conflits d'ilva dit kasimov
comment est ce que vous vous entendez
les arguments qui vient d'être qui
viennent d'être développées par françois
deweille jean léger entend souvent
l'argument selon lequel des arméniens se
représente dans le haut-karabagh depuis
des milliers d'années alors qu'une chose
d'eux les arméniens sont arrivés au
karabagh après 1828 de la région de
maragha de dix ans pour moi ça ne change
rien qui soit là depuis mille ans ou dix
mille en 100 ans ils sont des citoyens
lazare déjeuner ils sont sur leurs
terres les arméniens de coca va voir il
avait un statut une autonomie et que
l'azerbaïdjan s'engage est prêt
aujourd'hui à leur reconnaître un statut
et messieurs c'est des visions a parlé
de des régions contestées mais après il
a il a indiqué que l'arménie notre
pauvre indication sur ses autres régions
autres que nora haut karabagh cependant
ces régions sont toujours occupés par
l'arménie et que leurs populations à
savoir un million de personnes sont
chassés de ces territoires
d'autres choses aujourd'hui leur travail
barre n'est pas occupée par les
arméniens du haut karabagh le haut
karabagh est occupé par l'arménie de
l'état arménien donc que que l'arménie
même ses dirigeants ne l'a pas démonté
l'armée n'y prêtons un passage sur le
territoire azerbaïdjanais vers le haut
karabagh alors il faut parce que dans
cette histoire j'ai un pays appelé
difficulté parfois parce que de dire que
le haut-karabakh les arméniens du
karabagh qu ils revendiquent leur
autonomie ou leur indépendance mais
ensuite un couloir vers l'arménie donc
cela revient finalement donné que c'est
l'arménie qui il faut déjà dire les
choses comme ils sont et ensuite
peut-être voir comment est ce que sur
les conciliable avec le droit
international ou
autre françois devedjan qu'est ce que
vous répondez justement finalement les
arméniens ce n'est pas l'état d'arménie
alors devrait quand même répondre sur
surya effectivement tout un débat
savamment entretenu par la partie
azerbaïdjanaise sur les frontières les
frontières administratives du haut
karabagh on est comme ça pour que les
auditeurs comprennent sont des
frontières comment était à l'époque
stalinienne est en réalité la découpe
naturel de la partie arménienne est de
la partie azérie pour le dire un peu
simplement c'est la montagne et la
plaine et donc le coût voire de la chine
qui fait la jonction entre le karabagh
et l'arménie c'est la montagne et c'est
naturellement une zone arménienne ça
c'est que ça c'était le premier point le
deuxième point sur la présence de
l'arménie en art fa jusqu'au début du
mois de septembre il y avait 150 mille
habitants haut karabagh qui étaient des
habitants locaux qui n'étaient pas des
arméniens il y à un soutien
effectivement de l'arménie à ses frères
de l'art tard et je pense que c'est
relativement normal il est en tout cas
beaucoup moins important que le soutien
qui est apportée en particulier
militaires par la turquie à à
l'azerbaïdjan
il n'y a aucune revendication
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
arménien ou de l'état arménien en
général se déshabille dollar par la
seule position que demande l'état
arménien s'est laissé les habitants de
la retape déterminer eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
veulent vivre et j'ajouterais que on
nous explique les arméniens de l'artsakh
sont des citoyens l'azerbaïdjan est
qu'ils doivent vivre en paix sous le
régime azéri quand on ne se rappelle il
n'y a pas si longtemps que ça
les pogroms de bakou et de soumah et en
là les agressions constantes puis le
ceto 1994 par l'azerbaïdjan
on peut comprendre que les arméniens
n'ai pas spécialement envie
au delà de la situation actuelle de
vivre sous le régime de
de la turballe gens et je rajouterais
que l'art est aujourd'hui une démocratie
ce n'est pas le cas de l'azerbaïdjan il
fait une raison supplémentaire de ne pas
avoir envie de vivre sous ce régime
19 10 le bâti gasimov pour répondre
cette idée de référendum finalement pour
demander au peuple du haut karabagh bas
de quel côté ils veulent ils veulent
vivre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça pourrait
être une solution alors quand on parle
de référendum on parle de l'indépendance
alors que la région n'a jamais été
d'accord pour l'indépendance n'a jamais
été d'accord que son territoire soit
coupé pourrait créer un deuxième est
arménien les arméniens ils ont déterminé
leur statut ils ont un état qui
s'appelle arménie et tous les arméniens
vivent dans un état indépendant
les arméniens du haut karabagh lazare
des jeunes a toujours pas ce qu'il y ait
des principaux ministres une transe de
base selon ces principes là la position
d'hazard bayonnaise est la suivante
l'arménie se retire de cette région
occupée et que le statut du karabagh et
négocier la 0région est prêt à
reconnaître aux habitants du haut
karabagh le plus grand statut qui
n'existe même pas dans le dans la
pratique internationale donc il ne
s'agit pas de l'indépendance n'est pas
tout françois met donc il s'agit pas de
deux référendums deuxième marché de
l'hygiène et de conflits mais cependant
cela n'est pas contestée il ya quatre
résolutions des nations unies qui dit
que l'arménie occupe les territoires
hasard mais j'en ai aujourd'hui aussi
depuis un mois que la guerre continue
la guerre ne continue pas pour l'instant
sur le territoire administratif du haut
karabagh de taraba raymond bardet mais
il n'y a pas de les attaques hasard bd
jeunesse ne se dirige pas pour l'instant
vers le territoire du haut karabagh ces
atlas et opérations militaires
azerbaïdjanais se déroule pour l'instant
sur les autres territoires qui ne font
pas partie de haut karabagh et qui sont
occupés par l'arménie
françois devin gens vous répondait alors
deux points sur le référendum et le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
je ferai juste une comparaison un état
dont je pense qu'on sera tous d'accord
pour dire que c'est une démocratie de
liberté qui est la france aujourd'hui en
nouvelle calédonie depuis les accords de
matignon en 1988
ap mis en place un processus d'auto
d'auto dernier d'autodétermination
pardon des peuples de nouvelle calédonie
de l'ensemble de la population de beille
calédonie qui a déjà eu tout référendum
qui à chaque fois ont dit non nous
souhaitons rester français il en est
quand même prévu un troisième puisqu'on
voit clair un dom évoluer bon plutôt
vers le sens de l'indépendance
et si c'est le terme les termes des
accords de matignon de 1988
ce troisième référendum sur 30 ans
aboutit à une majorité de pour
l'indépendance la nouvelle calédonie
sera et deviendra indépendante
voilà donc là les les habitants de
l'artac ils mentent ils chez plus ni
moins qu'un que ce même processus pas et
pour l'aspect autodétermination et droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes sur
l'aspect mon contradicteur vient vient
nous expliquer que le conflit actuel ne
se déroule pas au karabagh mais en
azerbaïdjan il 0 dans la zone de
sécurité du karabagh parce que
effectivement la grande crainte est la
raison du du couloir de la team qui
relie le karabagh à à l'arménie c'est
que si le karabagh se retrouve
totalement isolé au sein de leurs deux
de l'azerbaïdjan et qu'il n'a plus de
liens avec l'arménie
c'est la fin des populations arméniennes
de d'arzacq et pardonnez moi de le dire
un peu crûment mais les populations sur
son vis-à-vis des arméniens ont un très
lourd passif disait un peu plus d'un
siècle un passif génocidaire qu'il
continue à nier et la confiance de le
des populations arméniennes tout elle
soit dans le monde
vis-à-vis de la sécurité que traitant
leur apporter un dictateur comme
monsieur à liège est plus que relative
et
je pense que ce n'est pas légitime merci
à tous les deux d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce soir en direct sur l'antenne
de rtl france merci à vous de dix balles
digue asimov
merci à vous françois deweille gens et
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la deuxième vague qui frappe de
plein fouet le pays emmanuel macro
réunira de conseil de défense mardi et
mercredi ce qui pourrait aboutir un
durcissement des mesures et puis
direction l'espagne le gouvernement a
annoncé un couvre-feu de 23 heures à 6
heures alors que le pays est durement
frappées par l'épidémie
restez avec nous sur rtl france a tout
de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense
tout au long des années l'alliance
atlantique s'est investi dans des
guerres qui n'étaient pas toujours
réellement en ligne avec ses objectifs
stricts
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet et 10 juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus dit libre haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu
des divergences avec quelle europe
pourront nous le faire
[Musique]
je n'oserais pas aller en ville parce
que s'ils me voyait comme ça il pourrait
envoyer à l'hôpital n'est ce pas
d'autant que certaines femmes se marient
à l'étranger moi je me suis mariée à un
homme qui vit de l'autre côté de la
frontière de la réalité je vis dans un
monde fantastique car mon mari est un
magicien
[Musique]
je me suis installé dans cette forêt
fait maintenant je suis forestiers comme
un grid
oh
j'ai réalisé que le seul endroit qui
puisse me convenir était comme dans un
conte de fées une forêt un sanctuaire
inaccessible où je pourrais vivre en
harmonie et m'imprégner de
l'environnement
à
[Musique]
hu
et
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française la situation sanitaire en
france avec un point sur les derniers
chiffres santé publique france dénombre
plus de 2700 malades du comité 19
hospitalisés en réanimation
trois cent cinquante sept nouveaux cas
graves ayant été admis dans ses services
au cours des dernières 24 heures un
chiffre qui n'avait plus été atteint
depuis avril
mais face à la progression exponentielle
de l'épidémie l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé libéraux qui
représente 14 mille médecins exhorte les
autorités à prendre des mesures
immédiates et drastiques dans un
communiqué publié ce vendredi lui rps
d'auvergne rhône-alpes apple a imposé un
couvre-feu dès 19h et instaurer un
confinement le week end d'une ultime
mesures afin d'éviter un confinement
généralisé de la population et une
proposition qui permet aux parents de
continuer à mettre leurs enfants à
l'école continue à travailler afin que
l'économie puisse tourner pour en parler
justement nous sommes avec jean-pierre
interne amian médecin radiologue
président du rps de président au pardon
de la de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé libéraux de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes
pierre-jean interne materna myans
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors face à la
progression exponentielle de l'épidémie
vous proposé l'élargissement immédiat
des horaires du couvre-feu à partir de
19 heures on le disait l'instauration
d'un confinement les samedis et
dimanches
ce soir est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que votre proposition est
entendu par l'exécutif ou qu'elles
pourraient être entendus disons que
j'espère qu'elle sera entendue par
l'exécutif
on a une accélération du temps politique
puisqu'ils un conseil de défense demain
je n'ai aucune nouvelle
j'ai informé tout à fait loyalement le
directeur de l'agencé régionale de santé
dès vendredi qu'on allait publier ce
communiqué parce que ça me semble est
vital que
on prenne position nous mais c'est un
libéraux de la région auvergne rhône ain
il a fait remonter à priori
l'information à monsieur seulement de la
direction générale de la santé
après j'ai pas de contacts
gouvernementaux par contre clairement
l'appel qu'on a lancée et virales
puisque je suis officiellement en
vacances
la première fois depuis on va dire
janvier et je peux vous dire que c'est
viral ensuite de dettes à plus d'une
dizaine de télévisions une quinzaine de
radios en moins de 48 heures donc je
pense qu'on a réellement été
interpellées on va dire la presse et par
ricochet l'opinion française parce que
cette épidémie devient très très
préoccupant très préoccupante parce que
très concrètement vous qu'est ce que
vous observez au quotidien alors très
concrètement en l'espace de 10 jours
lundi dernier on était à 48 patients on
va dire nouveau par jour fin de semaine
on était à quarante et un mille des
bulles à ce matin on est à 50 2000 le
professeur delfraissy du conseil
scientifique annonce pour amender
chiffre à 100 milles alors c'est quelque
part au milieu mais chose de sûr c'est
que on retrouve des niveaux beaucoup
plus inquiétant même que la première
vague
je vous rappelle qu'en première vague on
avait à peu près 2000 61 lits de coded
sur l'ensemble la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et avec trois régions en
france
les hôtes france ile de france et le
grand test est là avec pratiquement 60%
de la population sur notre région
auvergne rhône-alpes
on est déjà à trois milices d'ailleurs
mais les deux plus qu'au plus fort de la
crise vers le 6 avril et à les hisser
sur le gâteau alesi sur les camps le
gâteau si vous voulez à l'époque avec
d'aubilly on avait on avait la majorité
de nos lits de chirurgie disponibles
puisque on avait fait un arrêt brutal de
la chirurgie y avait un compte 8 de la
population
actuellement il ya des gens qui sont
encore opéré on essaye de vidéos avec
des services on va dire de médecine de
chirurgie
spectre on va dire reporter on vide les
services de soins de suite et de
réadaptation par exemple mon
établissement
on a fait sortir des gens par
anticipation qu'on va confier la
médecine libérale avec des infirmiers
des pharmaciens des kinés de ville de
manière à pouvoir obtenir des lits avec
de l'oxygène et absorber cette onde de
choc à mon avis avoir du mal à absorber
et nous couvrons ce qui est mis en
remplace actuellement il n'est pas
suffisant selon vous c'est une rigolade
si vous voulez le couvre-feu à 21h vous
avez le temps d'aller d'abord au
restaurant delfassy ce portable et vous
avez le temps d'organiser votre soirée
pyjama vous pouvez même et si plus
affinités en mariant avec le batlam
couché avec les copains on a vu sur
marie curie septembre avec la rentrée
étudiante et universitaire ça a été une
vraie catastrophe
la moitié de l'école de lyon centrale de
lyon a été contaminé parce qu'ils
avaient fait un bizutage et une soirée
festive d'intronisation c'est normal
c'est dans la culture des jeunes
le problème c'est que quand vous avez
les mêmes qui sont plus sur les berges
du rhône à on va dire touche touche ça
peut pas fonctionner on est bien trop
laxiste trop d'interaction sociale
aujourd'hui notamment dans la sphère
privée
bien sûr vous avez déjà fait un jour il
ya une interaction qui se créent et la
problématique qu'on est simple c'est on
doit la france est à genoux un genou à
terre avec cette première vague
on pensait avoir une reprise économique
en ces temps payé pas vous entendez le
patron du medef qui vous explique si on
re confine la france et la fin on vient
de se prendre un point de dettes on va
dire supplémentaires on a 10% de pib en
moins les gens sont au bout du rouleau
les soignants sont fatigués et vous
mettez en prime le fait qu' on va avoir
un impact maintenant du dur c'est à dire
que les gens vont commencer heureusement
leur lettre de licenciement parce que
les boîtes vont fermer les unes après
les autres
si vous rajoutez un confinement
économique c'est l'ensemble du tissu
économique français qui va commencer à
se déliter
donc si vous voulez y arriver mais
ni rock vous avez vous pousser les gens
à travailler pour maintenir un lien on
va dire avec le travail aux fins de
télétravail au maximum vous faites une
distribution de masques à toute la
population y compris aux jeunes même aux
enfants de manière à maintenir les
écoles ouvertes les universités ouvertes
avec des précautions vous allez faire
des rotations sur les cantines des
choses comme ça et puis vous rentrez
chez vous à 19h couvre-feu donc ça a
marché en première on considère
éco-compatible avait un équilibre entre
le fait de revenir à l'assemblée
si la france meurt ça c'est clair je
dirais quand vous avez 50 de mille
patients de nouveau par jour
ça veut dire que dans trois semaines
nous aurons à gérer nous médecins
pratiquement 260 décès de plus tous les
jours
rappelez-vous dans tous les villages de
france vous avez un monument aux morts
mais avec des noms qui s'égrènent de
façon effroyable un million cinq cent
mille soldats tués au front pour
défendre la patrie
très bien maintenant quand vous avez un
qui meurt à barkan c'est le drame
on n'est pas prêt à payer le prime et
quand nous en avait un qui meurt en
métropole c'était aussi un drap donc
c'est cette épidémie va emporter on va
dire où on est actuellement sur un train
d'être en 4000 décès on va rapidement
attendre quarante mille et plus
vous savez on a aimé la saison à
mulhouse on va adorer la saison bleus à
lyon malheureusement et et le fait de
laisser toutes les écoles ouvertes ya eu
un débat de savoir si c'était si ça
générait des foyers de contamination ou
non qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
à ce sujet là aujourd'hui il ya ya les
deux et deux éléments à prendre en
compte
le premier c'est qu'on sait pertinemment
que les skis sont porteurs mais ils sont
porteurs sains et ils n'ont quasiment
pas de symptômes les adolescents c'est
pratiquement la même chose mais par
contre si vous fermez les écoles si vous
fermez les classes même primaire qu'est
ce que vont faire les parents ils vont
aller garder les gosses dont vous allez
littéralement dézinguer l'économie
française
tendre il faut laisser avec des moyens
de protection alors là il faut ouvrir
les stocks de l'état
clairement
et faire en sorte que vous puissiez
avoir une à maintien de sociétaux
affectif dans cette société qui en a
besoin
outil bien aller à l'école imaginez les
gosses qui ont vécu le confinement
ceux qui étaient au travail qui on va à
qui on a essayé dans ces langues
étrangères ont fait du télétravail mais
ça va je pars forcément très bien donc
il ya déjà une belle chose ou comme une
perte de chance pour tous les patients
qu'on est obligé de repousser leur
projet y compris des pathologies
cancéreuses
le pendant la période de confinement où
je rappelle que sur ma région on a
littéralement plus disparaître 300
presque 300 cancer du sein on aurait dû
les voir on les a prévu puisqu'on n'a
pas pu faire d'exemple on n'a pas
rattrapé ce nombre de cancers
quand vous êtes impatients et que vous
avez inconscient le réaliser vous avez
une chance quand vous êtes métastatique
parce que votre traitement après trois
mois de retard n'est pas pu voir le
chirurgien
c'est plus du tout la même chose merci
beaucoup
pierre-jean ternes amian d'avoir répondu
à nos questions rappelle que vous êtes
médecin radiologue un président de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé libéraux de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes est l'actuel l'actualité en
france c'est aussi la suite du procès
des attentats janvier 2015 aujourd'hui
sous la dernière semaines
d'interrogatoires des accusés les
précisions de notre reporter katia
technique à la cour d'assises spéciale
de paris
ali riza paulette c'est le seul des onze
prévenus être jugé pour complicité il
est accusé d'avoir été le bras droit
dames et 10 koulibaly d'avoir négocié
une vente de voitures possiblement lié à
une vente d'armes qui auraient servi à
l'attentât de l'hyper cacher mais il nie
farouchement toute connaissance du
projet terroriste selon lui il avait une
dette à rembourser mehdi coulibaly rien
de plus il estime être en prison depuis
cinq ans pour une simple vente de
voitures alors pourtant l' enquête a
permis de trouver une liste d'armes
écrite de sa main il explique que
c'était pour un braquage et non pour un
attentat dans kate a permis de révéler
qu'il comptait partir en ci
lee mais dit il il comptait également
partir en thaïlande il l'a fait et au
liban au même moment juste après les
attentats
et donc il n'y a aucune preuve selon lui
de sa culpabilité mais sa version
déplaît aux avocats des parties civiles
je vous propose d'écouter m elie korchia
oui des éléments par rapport à ce qu'il
a pu dire
et puis je dirais que le principal c'est
sans doute cette sensation que nous
avions tous de l'entendre crier de
l'entendre manifester non pas des
réponses mais décrit en disant je ne
voulais pas aller en taule je ne voulais
pas aller en prison alors que le
président l'interrogé sur des faits
extrêmement précis et notamment la fuite
d'aleri zappos lattes juste après les
attentats
lorsqu'il part au liban du 12 au 19
janvier et que du liban le 17 janvier
il essaie de prendre la fuite où il
décide de partir pour passer le poste
frontière de masnaa en syrie et ça c'est
effectivement aussi un élément à charge
de son côté l'avocat d'ali risa paulette
le très véhément le trait débordant
accusé isabelle coûtant peyre estime
qu'il sert de bouc émissaire je propose
de l'écouter il faut montrer
montrez moi un bouc émissaire une
victime expiatoire on est comme ça et
vous de réfugiés à une époque dans un
autre contexte un emile zola était quand
même un écrivain important a soutenu une
séance de dreyfus il avait raison il a
quand même été condamné à l'époque
donc on essaye de faire la même chose
aujourd'hui autre interrogation ali riza
paulette était-il radicaliser ce qui
pourrait expliquer un passage à l'acte
pourrait damer dit à coulibaly et bien
l'audition de sa mère et de son frère
n'ont pas permis de statuer il aurait
traité sa mère de mécréante selon des
écoutes mais elle a nié disant que les
dialogues et et en turquie qu'on ne fait
pas traduire comme cela de nombreuses
questions subsistent sur ali riza bolat
et en europe à présent face au rebond de
l'épidémie plusieurs pays renforcent
leurs mesures de restriction c'est le
cas de l'italie mais aussi de l'espagne
où gouvernement a lancé un nouvel état
dallaire et a décrété un couvre feu sur
l'ensemble du territoire à l'exception
des îles canaries ont fait le point à
barcelone avec leslie cinglant et bien
de lourdes restrictions sont mises en
place en espagne
le couvre feu nocturne reste la
principale mesure prise par le
gouvernement pour tout le pays sauf les
îles canaries
alors il peut s'appliquer de 23 heures à
6 heures mais ce sont les régions qui
peuvent ajuster les horaires c'est le
juge nécessaire par exemple en catalogne
il s'applique de 22h à 6h alors le
gouvernement espagnol souhaite également
restreindre la mobilité entre les
régions d'espagne mais à nouveau ce sont
les communautés autonomes qui peuvent
décider celle l'appliquent ou non car la
volonté de l'espagne et de laisser le
choix aux communautés autonomes de
prendre des décisions pour les
principales mesures
alors les bars restaurants devront
fermer plus tôt pour s'adapter au couvre
feu
même si certaines régions les ont déjà
complètement fermée comme la catalogne
et la navarre
alors l'état d'urgence prévoit également
de restreindre à la capacité d'accueil
dans des lieux fermés de réduire les
groupes dans les espaces publics comme
privés car le chef du gouvernement
espagnol pedro sanchez indiqué que le
pays vit
situation extrême alors ces restrictions
s'appliquent pour une durée minimum de
15 jours un bilan sera effectué toutes
les deux semaines et l'état d'urgence
sera appliquée jusqu'en mai 2021
toujours en espagne les chauffeurs de
taxi de barcelone expriment leur colère
ils se sont réunis en nombre cet
après-midi pour bloquer les rues de la
capitale catalane rassemblés pour
demander plus d'être de la part du
gouvernement espagnol face aux
conséquences économiques de la pandémie
on écoute quelques-uns d'entre nous
revendiquons les aides que l'état nous a
refusé car nous sommes exclus des
dernières annonces
[Musique]
nous demandons aux banques d'être plus
souple parce que beaucoup d'entre nous
ont reçu un message annonçant que des
pénalités nous seront facturés nous
avons des baisses de revenus de plus de
80% et nous ne pouvons pas le prouver
les gens prennent une aide qu'ils vont
devoir rembourser ils l'apprennent sous
forme de prêt puis ils devront
rembourser les prêts de l'institut
officiel de crédit payer toutes leurs
dépenses tous les prêts personnels et
voilà la situation
et pour revenir sur la situation
sanitaire en espagne nous sommes avec
philippe emmanueli médecins exerçant en
espagne
philippe emmanueli merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors là
la seconde vague était attendue mais
peut-être pas d'une telle virulence est
ce que vous vous partagez sentiment ce
soir oui alors c'est vrai que moi
j'avais parlé de seconde vague dès la
première vague et beaucoup ne croyaient
pas cette seconde vague qui est pourtant
dans tous les livres d'infectiologie
classique et donc cette deuxième vague
est arrivée
finalement un petit peu comme prévu et
on sait que la deuxième vague est
toujours plus importante d'ailleurs que
la première vague
donc on peut dire que ati mais je ne
suis pas surpris par cette seconde vague
et effectivement nous sommes devant pour
faire face à ce cette seconde vague
l'espagne veut à la fois éviter à tout
prix art confinement mais en même temps
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire est ce que
finalement leur confinement n'est pas
inéluctable
oui bah si vous voulez c'est tout le
paradoxe de la situation dans laquelle
on se trouve aujourd'hui et le dernier
article du land 7 qui est paru il y à 24
heures sur l'efficacité des mesures de
distanciation sociale ou de confinement
va relancer le débat parce que le land 7
et bien trouve en gros que l'efficacité
des mesures sociales pour baisser le
fameux taux de reproduction du coded est
d'environ 23%
donc on n'est pas dans des taux non plus
extraordinaire c'est à dire que la
distanciation sociale ne permet pas de
supprimer la contagiosité et c'est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui avec toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises jusqu'à
maintenant et qui n'ont pas permis de
d'arrêter la reprise importante de cette
contagiosité
c'est cette question du confinement
justement est ce qu'elle est sur la
table aujourd'hui en espagne est ce
qu'on en parle avec des écoles ouvertes
comme en irlande par exemple
oui malheureusement la question du
confinement
revient et d'actualité alors par exemple
en catalogne
on imagine de nouvelles formes de
confinement et on a par exemple parlé
d'un confinement qui serait mis en place
uniquement du vendredi au dimanche de
façon effectivement à couper en quelque
sorte la poire en deux pour préserver en
partie les activités économiques
comment ça se passe dans votre cabinet
aujourd'hui vous constatez ce rebond de
l'épidémie c'est très concret vous le
voyez tous les jours
alors c'est très très intéressant ce
qu'il est les chiffres qu'on en espagne
et ce que nous on peut voir concrètement
sur le terrain est très intéressant
parce que on peut dire quand même que
c'est fondamentalement différent de la
première vague c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui effectivement tous les gens
qui se présentent avec des signes je
dirais assimilés à des rhumes wade signe
je dirais relativement léger et bien une
grande majorité d'entre eux reviennent
avec un test positif
donc on peut voir effectivement dans
notre pratique la réalité de
l'importance de la reprise épidémique et
de la contagiosité en revanche par
rapport à la première va louvoyer de
façon vraiment très nette
l'importance des tableaux respiratoires
aujourd'hui et bien effectivement tous
les cas qu'on voit sont relativement
bénins
et pour illustrer mon propos je vous ai
prévu donc deux petits graphiques pour
vous montrer vraiment comment ça se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans les chiffres
en espagne ça c'est la courbe de
mortalité effectivement qu'on pouvait
voir lors de la première vague vous
voyez que après avoir atteint un taux de
2 100 morts par jour le taux de
mortalité est monté en flèche très très
rapidement et aujourd'hui ce qu'on
observe effectivement en espagne c'est
plus une courbe de ce type là avec une
oscillation entre selon les jours entre
80 et 200 morts mais en revanche depuis
le début de la deuxième vague
on reste finalement dans une sorte de
plateau et sauver la banque
et bien alors comment s'explique c'est
très intéressant parce qu'il ya en gros
on peut dire qu'il ya deux hypothèses la
première hypothèse c'est simplement
qu'on on est à la sortie de l'été et
peut-être qu'ils
il ya un cofacteur si vous voulez au
qu'ovide 19 qu'on n'a pas identifiés et
peut-être que quand c'est ce qu'ont
factor ça peut être par exemple un petit
virus virus de la rue virus du rhume ou
quelque chose comme ça et quand ce qu
facteur est présent peut-être
effectivement qu'à ce moment là
l'épidémie est beaucoup plus mortel et
ça c'est peut-être le risque au concours
aujourd'hui c'est à dire effectivement
d'être dans une expansion incroyable de
l'épidémie avec un taux de mortalité qui
est relativement modérée et si ce
potentiel cofacteur arrive et bien à ce
moment là on va se retrouver avec une
mortalité extrêmement importante
ça n'est qu'une hypothèse mais on ne
peut pas expliquer si vous voulez de
façon claire ce différentiel de
mortalité entre la première vague et la
deuxième balle
il ya quand même une deuxième hypothèse
qui est difficile aussi validé parce
qu'on n'a pas les mêmes outils
scientifiques pendant la première et la
deuxième vague
c'est le fait que la distanciation
social aurait permis de limiter la
charge virale est qu'aujourd'hui les
gens qui sont contaminés en quelque
sorte une charge virale bien inférieures
à celles de la première vague et qu'à ce
moment là ils développent des formes
beaucoup moins grave et que finalement
au fond cette cette expansion de la
pandémie se fait finalement avec un coût
en terme de mortalité moins important
merci beaucoup
philippe emmanueli pour votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes médecin français
exerçant en espagne et c'est la fin de
cette émission mais restez avec nous on
va se retrouver dans quelques minutes
dans moins de dix minutes pour faire un
point complet sur l'actualité a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense ont donné tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs tels la situation s'est
aggravée avec le début d' attaques
contre la frégate courbet et 10 juillet
les menaces sur contre la grèce et la
présence de thua d'ist syriens venus dit
libre haut karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne de 7 à
l'europe d'être en capacité d'assumer la
responsabilité de sa propre sécurité et
d'agir de manière autonome quand c'est
nécessaire
mais compte tenu des divergences